I went to see smile and I didn't know
you were in it Kyle
and I wrote this down because I anyone
who listens to this podcast knows I'm a
big car or not
Yeah just they know it and I'm always
upset because Ryan you know there's just
not many good ones like I just said it
but this movie
was not only scared me at times but with
a lot of horror movies don't do is they
establish sort of a character and a
relationship and by the time the movie's
10 minutes in you don't give a [ __ ]
usually but I cared about you and then I
I I I began to slowly care about you as
because because you don't come in till I
mean you kind of like yeah come in and
then you're like oh oh [ __ ] I won't give
anything away you can give it away now
it's out spoiled no no people have to go
see this especially if you like horror
movies this worked this is one of the
few out there so why did you like it
like would it like did it scare you I
always want to know what people think
you know what makes your skin crawl at
times you know that scene where you're
in the room and then all of a sudden the
girl's just standing there smiling at
you and then you know you kind of like
oh my God what's what's happening and
what she does next is pretty it's just
like the build like there's a bill
there's not just a sound that makes you
go oh yeah I'm a jump scare it was
it was sort of refreshing got it and you
went through a lot yeah with your
character I mean that those are movies
are not easy to do or pull off and you
got to pull off that you're not crazy
but you're crazy right but you're not
crazy totally it's so hard I think it's
probably one of like
well Kyle do you think I probably think
that playing anxiety even though I'm
always anxious me too in life is
probably one of the hardest and I've
always felt that way like it's one of
the hardest acting things because it's
like I don't know why I can be sad or
happy or whatever but anxious is hard so
that so yeah it's tough it's tough do
you guys I'll ask you know do you trust
does it take you time to trust the
director because when you're being so
vulnerable You're like do I look like an
idiot doing this is this real is this or
do you just let go and they've learned
to just say hey I'm going to do my part
and he'll tell me if it's bad well I
think Kyle the thing that I loved about
Kyle like right off the bat which
clearly as like when you watch the movie
there's such a connection between us
there's such a chemistry and energy like
a real like we're playing ball you know
what I mean we have like a super you
know whatever
um and by the way everyone chemistry if
you don't get like it's not like you
need camp like you it's not like
chemistry off screen I mean we're
friends but I'm saying like what if one
person is a good actor and the other
person's not it won't look like there's
chemistry if you know if as long as both
people are good actors it will you know
what I'm committed really committed yes
exactly and like and also we like really
got along like as friends but anyways so
I think what I loved about Kyle is that
I can tell he's the type of actor I can
tell that he is the type of actor who
has been working
long enough to under to know how to make
stuff and this has nothing to do with
smile but stuff that isn't written well
or difficult directors and still kill it
not that Parker was difficult not that
it wasn't written well just that those
types of actors are the ones that can do
anything you know what I mean so I came
in and so did Kyle I think as I call it
director proof as in no matter what the
director is doing you can do your job
and I think that it took me a little
while to lighten let up on that a little
bit and then once I did I unders like
Parker
had such a vision and was so specific
and was amazing it's just that I think I
was a bit um
I'm just I I don't trust any directors
at first maybe you don't trust people at
first well definitely well I also